[Music]
the taliban swift return to power has
shocked the world
and humiliated america
[Music]
it marks the end of a 20-year campaign
which has highlighted america's failures
in military planning
intelligence and nation building
above all
it has shown america failing to protect
those it is sworn to defend
it's the right
and the responsibility of afghan people
alone
to decide their future
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
how will this damage america's long-term
global standing and the future security
of the world
our experts answer your questions
how did the afghan government and army
collapse so easily
i think the ultimate reason the afghan
army collapsed so spectacularly in the
early weeks of august
was that it wasn't out fought by the
taliban on the battlefield militarily it
was effectively outwitted the taliban
turned up to local areas and said to
local militia leaders and afghan troops
look you can either fight for the afghan
state that is going to be abandoned by
the americans in a few weeks or you can
give up now and save your families save
your lives and will give you free
passage
and it did that in district by district
flipping individual afghan brigades and
battalions so yeah it was
extraordinarily um
deft on the part of the taliban and
extraordinary incompetence on the part
of the americans of not seeing this
coming i mean we you know we had
conversations with very senior uh
american government officials only a few
days before this happened where they
were saying no there's absolutely no
chance of that happening it'll be fine
the government will
will be you know remain in charge and
they just didn't know what they were
talking about
why was america in afghanistan in the
first place
america went into afghanistan in the
first place because uh osama bin laden
and al-qaeda the the group that carried
out the terrorist attacks on new york
and washington of september the 11th
2001 uh were being sheltered by the the
taliban government there and they they
went in to
drive uh al-qaeda out of uh afghanistan
and in the process they overthrew the
afghan government and that happened
incredibly quickly
and then they weren't quite sure what to
do next and that was when the sort of
the mission creep came in you know how
do you get out what how do you establish
um a non-terrible or less terrible uh
government in afghanistan that won't
harbor terrorists again
and that turned out to be extremely
difficult it was very easy to overthrow
uh the taliban uh but it was extremely
hard to turn uh afghanistan into um a
a democracy of any kind let alone a
well-run one and they've spent sort of
20 years trying to figure out how to do
that
with as we can see now
very little success
why was america unable to create a
functioning government in afghanistan
america struggled to create a
functioning government in afghanistan
for lots of reasons
one of those reasons i think is that
what happened very early on in the
invasion in the early 2000s was that it
created a highly centralized afghan
state lots of power was vested in kabul
it essentially disenfranchised lots of
power brokers in afghanistan who for
decades had enormous amounts of power
communities in the north of afghanistan
on the fringes near key border towns
and the the the power of tribe was very
very important here you know tribes that
had long held key border crossings that
were very important felt disenfranchised
by a central government that had
accumulated power for itself that's one
reason i think the taliban was able to
flip so many of these areas so quickly
in the last month or so the americans
you know they could they could paper
over a lot because it's a superpower and
they did have uh militarily the power to
hold the taliban off for as long as they
chose to um and they did have enough
money to to keep the state functioning
but to make it able to function without
any help at all that was very long-term
project um and one that
ultimately uh donald trump and joe biden
decided they didn't wish to pursue so
they pulled the plug with the disastrous
consequences that we've just seen
why is the taliban's takeover of
afghanistan so humiliating for america
there are lots of people i think in the
united states and elsewhere who thought
it was perhaps the right time for
america to leave afghanistan but
the the manner in which it was done the
haste with which it was conducted the
betrayal of lots of afghan allies the
sense that america was fixated and
entirely focused on evacuating its
nationals rather than helping those who
had fought alongside it for 20 years
that that said something um very
damaging about america's character and
america's policy there was a point where
you could have said that um a sort of
slapdash america first foreign policy
was just
a temporary blip because donald trump
was in charge but this was taking place
under a
democratic president who prided himself
on his foreign policy knowledge and he
turned out to be no better uh in this
case than his predecessor possibly worse
that's that's a huge problem for
america's image at least in in the short
run and that's going to affect its
ability to deter its enemies and
reassure its allies and friends
what type of government will the taliban
form and how will they govern
the taliban say they want an open
inclusive islamic government
i suspect the emphasis will be on the
third of those and not very much on the
first two of those they want to keep the
international community on side they
want to present a different image to the
world of a less brutal harsh force uh
one that they say has reformed and i
think they want to keep the aid flowing
they want to ensure that they don't
provoke a backlash to their rule
straight away
so they've made all the right noises but
i think it's worth being very clear-eyed
about this in areas that were under
their control in the past and this is
this is well documented by organizations
like human rights watch the ngo
girls education was extremely limited
and we saw lots of the same curbs on art
on media on music on free expression on
religious freedom on personal liberties
that we did under their previous emirate
or previous government in the 1990s
but i don't think that the the
fundamental
ideological cast of the movement has
changed very much at all
even just very recently in the areas
that they've taken over we have seen
them
going into workplaces telling women
you must go home never come back again
and uh why don't you get your male
relatives to come and take your jobs
they'd be knocking on people's doors and
saying if there are any single women in
this household they must come out now
and they say marry a taliban fighter
that's how they see that that is what
they consider to be justice that's what
they consider to be the appropriate way
of running a society and it's possible
that they may moderate that slightly uh
in the cities but uh it's pretty clear
what direction the country is going in
the question is how far it moves in that
direction and um i think the scenes of
people
risking their lives to try to get out
suggests what afghans think is going to
happen
is biden to blame for this failure in
afghanistan
joe biden deserves responsibility for
the manner of withdrawal and of course
the decision to pull america completely
out today there's no doubt about that he
himself said in his press conference he
he didn't want to hand this this
responsibility on to a fifth american
president
but i think it's also worth knowing that
lots of presidents have contributed to
this mess not just not just biden in
sort of delivering the final uh decision
donald trump signed a
rather flawed agreement with the taliban
in which he effectively agreed to pull
all american troops out by may 1st of
this year in exchange for very little
but even going before that we saw george
w bush initiate the iraq war which was
distracted from the afghan campaign um
and we saw barack obama who also had a
rather substantial surge of american
forces in 2010 or so which also failed
so in some ways every american president
has tried their hand at this problem
they've all made various mistakes but of
course it is joe biden who will be
associated with the um with the final
withdrawal and the chaos that
accompanied
will the taliban's takeover of
afghanistan affect the world
what i think we're likely to see now and
we've seen hints off in the chaos at
kabul airport is afghans desperate to
leave the country there's going to be
substantial refugee flows
already internally away from provincial
towns towards kabul kabul is full of
refugees and out of afghanistan towards
neighboring areas iran central asia
pakistan that will have serious
consequences for those countries which
may not be in great shape to take more
afghan refugees but i think it will also
affect europe so you know apart from the
risk of a resurgent al-qaeda
resurgent militancy the ideological
effects of all of that i think refugees
are going to be perhaps one of the most
important legacies of the military
events that we've seen in the past few
days
i'm robert guest the foreign editor of
the economist
if you'd like to read more of our
afghanistan coverage please click on the
link
thank you very much for watching
you